[Music]
foreign
lecture so we've been talking about how
to integrate non-linear differential
equations x dot equals f of x things
like the Lorenz 1963 butterfly attractor
system and today I'm going to show you
how instead of integrating a single
trajectory along that system we can
actually integrate a big bundle or a
cube of initial conditions and integrate
them all along the system I'm actually
just going to run this code I'll I'll
walk you through this in a minute but
this is the kind of thing I'm going to
talk about is how do you take a big cube
of initial conditions and integrate them
through this differential equation all
it wants to see where they go
so this is a very very useful thing to
do in dynamical systems is not to just
look at one trajectory but to look at a
kind of a bundle of nearby trajectories
at least in chaotic systems I find that
useful
and I'm specifically going to talk about
how do we do this in a way that is
efficient in languages like Python and
Matlab that are not compiled because the
naive way you might think of doing this
by writing a big for Loop is totally
going to grind your computer to a halt
or at least it could so I'm going to
talk about why we would want to
integrate more than one trajectory at
once and what that means physically and
also how to compute these things
efficiently in languages like Python and
Matlab and when I say compiled you know
when I was a kid growing up
computers were so slow uh it really
mattered that you compiled your code
into machine code you know assembly code
that would then run at a low level on
your computer
now a lot of times a lot of my students
don't even know the difference between
compiled code and interpreted code
because you know it's still so fast to
run Matlab and python most of the time
even though Matlab and python is not are
not pre-compiled languages you don't
write a code then hit compile and have
it you know optimize it into really
efficient assembly code that runs on
your your processors
it kind of does that on the fly as
needed that's an interpreted language
and that can be really really slow if
you have a bunch of nested for Loops for
example to walk through all of these
initial conditions that's an example
where you definitely don't want to do
that in python or Matlab and instead if
there's any way to leverage a vectorized
operation or a matrix Vector product or
anything that's kind of in terms of
linear algebra
then you can use these so Matlab and
python are both built on top of some
compiled for Tran linear algebra codes
and so if you can access those kind of
linear algebra routines by coding this
up in a smart way your code could be you
know tens hundreds thousands of times
faster okay so pretty important thing to
know if you're getting serious into
computation is how to compute things in
an efficient way using vectorized
operations when your language is not
compiled if this was compiled C code or
Fortran code it really wouldn't matter
if I had nested for Loops because it's
going to optimize that pretty
efficiently anyway when it compiles it
okay I'm gonna run this one more time
because it looks super cool what I'm
doing here is I'm starting with an
initial condition zero zero zero and I'm
creating a large cube of initial
conditions of you know side length you
know minus 20 to 20 so length 40 by 40
by 40. so that's what I'm doing here I
think if I just run this
code you'll see this is my initial cube
in blue plotted on top of the lorenza
tractor
and when I run the code it's going to
integrate all of those particles forward
in time
very very quickly so it's kind of just
cranking through and running these
pretty quickly through uh through this
differential equation I believe this is
my fast code that's leveraging those
kind of vectorized compiled Fortran guts
in Matlab I'll tell you how in a minute
but you can see cool stuff happens that
Cube initially starts off off of that
white Lorenzo tractor and very quickly
it kind of glues on and adheres onto
this this attractor that's why it's
called an attractor because it attracts
these blue points and then they kind of
mix and smear onto that attractor okay
it's also called a strange attractor
and what I find cool is that you can
also kind of decrease
the size of that that cube of initial
conditions so maybe I want to look at
um
this little cube right here so you can
see I think just a little teeny bit this
blue cube right here
and what we're going to do is now we're
going to integrate that Cube forward
and you can almost think of that as a
little bit of uncertainty on that
initial condition you can think of this
as an initial condition with some
uniform uncertainty in X and Y and Z and
you see that as time goes on eventually
that that uncertainty causes those
trajectories even though they started
close eventually they go to very very
different places and that's what we need
mean what we mean by chaos and sensitive
dependence on initial conditions is even
though that cube of particles started
close by to that initial condition after
some amount of time they kind of smear
out to very different places on this
attractor
and I can do this for an even smaller uh
an even smaller cube of particles now
this has length 0.1 and I don't think
you can even see it it's teeny tiny but
if I run this code you're going to see
this thing moving around
and so now you can see my little blue
particle that's actually a whole bundle
of trajectories moving around but
because they started at such a close
proximity they stay close to each other
they Shadow each other
uh but eventually they're going to start
stretching pretty much when they hit
this Saddle Point there's a saddle point
in this dynamical system right about
there and when those particles got close
to the saddle point they sheared and
they started stretching out and again
that sensitive dependence on initial
condition that's a Hallmark of chaos
that's often driven by saddle points in
the flow that kind of spread out
particles even if they start very close
the saddle shoots them out to different
lobes of the attractor
so these are the kind
of the Kion and analyze is running a big
bundle of trajectories through the code
um
if I do this using my slow code you'll
see that it runs a lot slower so I'm
just going to run my slow code that's
doing this with for Loops you can see
that it still is going you know it still
is integrating the solution but it's
kind of much much slower than it was in
the other case where it was already
mixed and folded by now Okay so this
code is taking that initial cube of
initial conditions and it's literally
writing a for Loop let me see if I can
do this in a place that's not going to
irritate me later
for my cube of initial conditions in X
and Y in Z it literally created a like
I'm literally going through a for Loop
you know this is the I index for the X
particles the J index for the the Y
position of the particles and the K
index for the Z or Z position of the
particles and I'm writing a big nested
for Loop 4i equals you know 1 to 40 4J
equals one to forty for k equals one to
forty integrate this trajectory
integrate that trajectory integrate the
next trajectory and that's what's
happening here it's very very slow it's
very very inefficient okay because for
Loops in a non-compiled language like
Matlab or python are typically very very
slow because it's kind of every time
every inside of that for Loop so I've
got like four I Four J
4K you know integrate
every time inside of this Loop the code
is kind of locally compiling this
instruction here which is very expensive
and it's doing that every single time
inside of this looping through this Cube
and that's why this slow code is
grinding to a halt it's very very slow
I wrote this code 10 years ago to show
my my undergrad class uh you know in
intro scientific Computing class and it
ground to a halt even slower 10 years
ago so this is actually for me
relatively fast compared to how slow it
was when I wrote this code 10 years ago
but it's still slower than the
vectorized version
uh and just to remind you this version
here
I'm just going to comment these guys out
so we're comparing Apples to Apples my
vectorized version
is
like you can see it just ripping through
these particles cranking through because
it's not based on this nested for loop
it's integrating every single chunk of
particles it takes this whole cube of
particles and I'm basically finding a
clever way of writing that rk4 single
step so it crunches through all the
points at once it computes using linear
algebra compiled Fortran linear algebra
it's stepping all of these one DT
forward at once which is way more
efficient than this for Loop so let me
get into the code and show you real
quick
um I'll just go through the slow lorentz
first because it's easier it's just a
bunch of for Loops so I have my grid of
initial conditions which in Matlab and
python both I believe you just use this
mesh grid to create this kind of cube
given a mesh in X and Y and Z and then
our initial conditions are going to be
that big cube of particles
I'm going to you know scatter plot all
of those particles so you can see the
cube
and then the trajectory is really easy
you know we're going to integrate in
increments of 0.01 up to a big T of four
and we're going to step through this
time index L and then for each index for
I for J for K I think here I call it for
one to length of the X Vector for J
equals one to the length of the Y Vector
for k equals one to the length the Z
Vector that's just a big nested for Loop
what I'm doing is I'm taking that
initial condition that defines a single
initial condition
and that single initial condition is
literally the i j k position of my my
array of particles I'm stepping that
forward using my rk4 single stepper and
I repeat and I repeat and I repeat for
every point in Z in y and x and then in
time I do this thing and again nested
for Loops are a nightmare in Matlab and
python any language that's not compiled
because what it's doing is it's kind of
compiling this on the fly every single
time so it's doing that like thousands
and thousands and thousands of times
very expensive
in a compiled language like C or Fortran
this would be totally fair game it'll
compile this into something super
efficient and it won't be slow any
slower hardly than doing the vectorized
calculation
so this is the slow code you should
avoid doing big nested for Loops if you
can and instead you should do vectorized
operations
and actually my rk4 single step the way
I wrote it if I can bring this code up
really quickly
it actually is written in a way that's
incredibly General so this why not does
not just have to be a vector of initial
like an initial condition it can be a
whole four-dimensional tensor like an
array of initial conditions or a kind of
a matrix of initial conditions or a cube
of initial conditions if you like and
nothing in this code changes it'll
basically output
the time derivative D DT I'm sorry it'll
update it'll output the next time step
of all of those points so
if y naught is a single initial
condition it'll advance that one time
step forward if y naught is a huge cube
of initial conditions it will update all
of those cube of initial conditions into
y out it'll step them all forward in
time
as long as this function my right hand
side function
x dot equals F of in this case in Matlab
and in Python it's defined as T comma X
as long as my differential equation as
long as this function fun on the right
hand side is defined so that it can take
in an array of x's and evaluate them all
at once to give you an array of DX DTS
and so that's literally uh kind of this
code does that and when I go to Lorenz
fast and I Define the same grid of
initial conditions and I am plotting
them here
what I'm doing is I don't have a big
nested for Loop for all of these
particle positions I just have a loop
for time I'm time stepping from DT to DT
to DT and at each step I use this
lorentz 3D code to return DX DT at this
entire cube of initial conditions so
this is a custom code I wrote here
Lorenz 3D it Returns the vector field at
every single initial condition and rk4
single step can use that to walk these
all forward all at once and this is
going to be way more efficient because
it's using just Matrix multiplications
which are using compiled Fortran code
so if I go into lorentz 3D
this code it looks a little nastier than
lorentz maybe I'll pull up Lorenz just
so you can compare
lorentz was pretty simple it took in a
single point x a single position you
know x y z and it returned DX DT which
is a three vector
and lorentz 3D is exactly the same code
except it says
you know this x X1 X2 X3 and returning
DX
those can be arrays of initial
conditions so I have my my you know Y2
this is a cube of i j and k indices of Y
of X of Z and it's going to return this
Big Y dot for all of those initial
conditions so you can convince yourself
that these you know comma colon comma
colon comma colon this is basically a
big array of initial conditions in y and
it's going to return a big array of
dydts that my rk4 single stepper can
work with and everything here is just
Matrix algebra so it's going to be
really fast really efficient compiled uh
Fortran code
and so again I'm just going to run this
one more time so you can see the impact
of you know this is the slow algorithm
in the olden days it was like one update
then another update
then another update my computer you know
must be about eight times faster now
okay but this is still slow
compared
let me close all compared to using this
fast vectorized calculation that's what
it's called when you leverage this
Matrix algebra it's called vectorization
and this is the vectorized code it's way
way faster way way better okay I love
this example I like this also because it
shows you things you want to do with
chaotic systems I want to run a grid of
initial conditions through to see how it
behaves in time
and maybe I'll do my um
I'll integrate for a little bit longer
because I can because it's fast and I'm
going to use my smaller set of initial
conditions that have so this one was
minus 20 to 20 that big big Cube this
cube is teeny tiny it's minus 0.1 to 0.1
around my initial condition so this is a
much tighter initial Cube
whoops you should be able to see it and
we can see this little blue cube of
initial conditions whipping around it's
staying pretty coherent because the
original you know uncertainty in my
initial condition was pretty small minus
0.1 to 0.1 but eventually when it gets
by that saddle it starts to shear and
stretch and eventually it's going to
fold and stretch on this chaotic
attractor that's what it means to be
chaotic is initial conditions that start
really close to each other eventually
smear out and go very far away and are
kind of indistinguishable after a long
enough time t
and that's what you see here
I also think this is kind of cool
because in this example the view is
rotating so you can kind of see it it
looks neat so this is an example of you
know things you can code up yourself if
you want to and by this point in time T
all of my trajectories are kind of all
spread out uh kind of chaotically across
this tractor and it'll be very hard to
tell which one came from where in that
little initial Cube
cool okay so that's uh that's this
example
all of this code is in Python also so
Alan Captain aglu ported this code over
to python I'm not going to go through
all of the guts again because this is
not about the coding it's about you know
compiled versus non-compiled and
uncertainty and vectorized versus
non-vectorized it's the exact same story
in in Python really to be honest so this
is Alan's code in Python again we're
going to use this rk4 single step
and
[Music]
um
you know the slow code is going to use
this massive massive nested for Loop of
you know 4i 4J 4K and this is going to
be very very slow
um he actually uses the the time command
here to compute exactly how long this
takes to run which I think is nice so
you can quantitatively compare the time
of the slow algorithm and the fast
algorithm
and then the fast algorithm here oh this
is the fast one I'm sorry
no this is slow this is the slow one I'm
confusing myself the fast one
uh again rk4 single step doesn't change
I wrote this code to be generic so it
could take a big array of initial
conditions and this is actually a good
exercise for you is to convince yourself
that this code still would work it would
still update as long as even if y naught
was an array of initial conditions as
long as this function returns that same
shaped array of dydts of the right hand
sides
um
and it looks like in Python you don't
even have to change
um the lorentz function unless I'm
confused about something here
and here
essentially
uh in in this fast version that Alan
wrote this rk4 single step is being
applied to that Lorenz Vector field but
on this massive array of initial
conditions and so this is actually nicer
in in Python because you don't have to
modify this lorentz function to return a
vector of dydts or DX DTS it apparently
already Works to return that
and I'm going to say that again rk4
single step will work on this cube of
initial conditions as long as my right
hand side function my lorentz function
here Returns the same shaped cube of DX
DTS or dydts and so that's what's
Happening Here and Now you see that his
code was way faster the slow code took
14 seconds this code took 0.08 seconds
so way way way faster two orders of
magnitude faster
um
once you use this vectorized computation
so really really cool and again this
gets on a lot of the the aspects that I
want you to be thinking about what
happens in a chaotic system when I have
nearby initial conditions they stretch
and fold but not only that how do I do
that efficiently in my language of
choice like python or Matlab if they're
non-compiled languages
okay cool that
would thank you for listening
[Music]